the jurgen experience so this is another
uh thing that i point out in the book is
that we're never bored anymore
so as we evolved boredom is this
evolutionary discomfort that basically
told us
whatever you're spending your time on
right now it's not an efficient use of
your time
so go find something else now in the
past this would be like let's say you're
picking berries from a bush you've
picked the easiest to pick ones
well if we didn't have the skew of
boredom we'd be like reaching into the
very back for the berries that are hard
to pick but
they become successfully harder to pick
because we've picked all these different
ones right
boredom would kick on and be like hey
your return on your time invested has
worn thin
move on to another bush right but
nowadays
with this influx of media we have people
spend
11 hours a day engaging with digital
media
is that real yeah 11 and that's the
average so
what you want to hear an even crazier
thing yeah
okay so i'm a i'm a professor at
university of nevada las vegas
and one of the classes i teach is an
intro class so it's got about 150
students
and some media class i teach in the
journalism department
first day of class i'll talk about how
just how things have changed with media
you know it's like we live
2.5 million years with no media in our
lives and now it's become our lives and
then i will ask
all right i want everyone to pull out
your phone right now i want you to look
at your screen time
tell me how much you have who thinks i
have the highest
we'll start to go through people i've
had people you know seven hours 45
minutes
eight hours 50 minutes 9 hours 16
minutes
it's like that's your entire day
all on that cell phone right so nowadays
when we have this discomfort of boredom
kick
in we have a super easy escape from it
right right we're not forced to be like
okay what am i doing with my time
is there something better i could be
doing we just pull out our phone
and you see this right anytime people
have one moment of
solitude or inactivity it's like oh
might as well just check my phone
it's brutal when you see people on dates
they're not even talking to each other
they're just looking at each other's
phones
yeah go wow people at dinner it's like
yeah
it's like you're in front of an actual
person yeah and you prefer to
communicate
in digital with someone who's not even
there
totally and um what's interesting about
boredom is when oftentimes when boredom
would kick on we would go
uh inward sort of mind wander and
mind wandering it gives you your brain
some time to like reset and revive
whereas anytime you're focused on the
outside world your brain
is actively processing information so
this is kind of like
in the book i compare it to lifting away
when you're
having a conversation looking at your
phone watching a screen whatever you're
doing if you're
focusing on the outside world your brain
is working and it's lifting
when you go inward your brain goes into
this default mode network which is like
a rest period
right so now because every time we're
bored we just pull out that
screen and focus more our brains are
just constantly being worked and
overworked and overworked
this is associated with just burnout
anxiety etc
yeah it's there's some real benefits to
boredom in terms of creativity as well
like oh totally boredom is really good
for coming up with new ideas yeah and
there's actually research behind this
they've done studies where they'll have
they'll have people watch something
really boring like a video of people
folding laundry just like they bore the
[ __ ] out of these participants
and then they have them come up with
take these different creativity tests
that scientists use
and the people who were bored come up
with more better
uh solutions and responses than the
people who had been stimulated the whole
time
and you think about this i mean just in
terms of anecdotes from creators it's
like
you need time to just sit and be with
yourself and have these
weird ideas bubble to the surface if you
never have that
you're not letting that the weird stuff
come out you know i mean
like do you experience this when you're
trying to think of
stuff in your own work yeah you have to
have discomfort the worst
thing that could ever happen to me from
writing is to just open the browser
and start let me just google this real
quick and see
it's like i play little games of myself
like i'll be in the middle of writing
i'm like what does that mean
really and then i'll google it like shut
the [ __ ] up and get get back to work
yeah
because like i'm just being distracted
i'm just distracting myself and
sometimes i'll allow myself a couple of
minutes of distraction
before i get mad but really i shouldn't
allow myself any
i should just keep working and sometimes
people say
i can't write i just stare at the screen
and nothing comes down like yeah that's
what's supposed to happen
yeah that's how it works man you're
supposed to [ __ ] stare at the screen
yeah and then you just write some
nonsense and eventually something good
will come out of that
yeah but if you just bail because you
don't like the staring at the screen
part and nothing's coming out
guess what you're never going to write
anything congratulations so then you'll
be at the whim
of whatever random spontaneous
creativity just
pops into your head throughout the day
yeah and sometimes you'll get some
and sometimes you won't yeah but
pressfield talks about that in the war
of art have you read that book
uh i haven't read that book i've heard
it's a very small book but it's really
good it's great for writers
and it's he's basically says he he talks
about the muse
as if the muse is a real thing and he's
like treat it like it's a real thing
treat it like
you're a professional and you're there
to summon the muse and if you just show
up every day and do that work
it will come it will come to you and it
will bestow upon you these creative
ideas
but if you don't do that if you don't
sit down and be
discomfort to be uncomfortable rather
rather
it won't happen and in this day and age
like you said we're so accustomed
to having our any boredom
alleviated by our phone yeah so in the
book too i talk about
you hear all this stuff that's like
break up with your phone
less time on your phone here are a
thousand different ways to use your
phone less
yes that is important but the problem is
is a lot of times
when people go okay i'm gonna use my
phone less so they put their phone in
you know safe or whatever weird habit
they've developed but then they go watch
netflix it's like your brain doesn't
know the damn difference between the
screen on your phone and the screen on
your tv the point is that you need to
remove yourself
from this outside media that's totally
just weaved its way
into your life like stimulating you with
nothing
yeah yeah the switch from phone to
netflix is like going i'm quitting
smoking but i'm gonna go buy some red
man and just pack that in
real hard you know yeah same thing we're
all aware
that there's this immense gravity that
comes from the digital world
it's it's immense it's just constantly
pulling you in with new content and new
distractions and this is one of them
this [ __ ] thing that you and i are on
that's it's ironic this is we're talking
[ __ ] about what we actually are doing
right now
but they you know they pull you
they pull you and we all know that it's
probably not
the best way to live but it's so hard to
break
the addiction i mean it's it's amazing
right it's amazing that
i can pull up a podcast and listen to
almost whoever i want their thoughts and
get these new ideas but at the same time
it's like if that's
all you're spending your time doing
there's some downsides we need to offset
it that i you know i don't necessarily
think the answer is to
go live in the woods in alaska for the
rest of your life although that'd be
pretty
cool if you did more power to you but
figuring out like how do we how do we
balance this all and have these moments
where we have
you know solitude go more inward and
aren't as stimulated
so one thing that you know after i am
standing out there
in solitude when i get home i start
researching you know what are the
benefits of solitude because we know
that
the data shows that being lonely isn't
good for us
but there's the difference between
loneliness and solitude like solitude is
electing to be
by yourself and using that time for sort
of introspection
and the scientists that i talked to they
said yeah you really need this because
a lot of times people are more conductor
circuits and they
they don't do well when they're alone at
all this is part of the reason we have
such a loneliness problem but if you can
like build this
build this capacity be alone they call
it like that can serve you well in a
long time and it also
breeds deeper thinking creativity i mean
it's like there's a reason that
thousands of years of religious
tradition
they have people who go and spend this
time alone out of nature i mean
jesus was in the desert for 40 days the
buddha exited the
palace gates you know and spent a bunch
of time alone and in solitude
even abraham lincoln used solitude and
for all his a lot of his writing
and stuff like that and i feel like
people don't have that as much anymore
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only
on spotify watch back catalog jre videos
on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience